disclaimer I own nothing so after two
really awesome seasons Netflix is
controversial series about a gun-toting
antihero set in the Marvel Universe
finally met its untimely demise at the
hand of corporate politics well I think
the show has some of the best acting in
a comic book based series to date and
even had some really memorable moments
as a huge fan of The Punisher I felt it
lacked severely in one major area that
being the actual Punisher you know I
don't just mean I was bored because of
the show's oftentimes very noticeable
pacing issues or the fact that Frank
seemed to where the skull vest as little
as possible so you take the show more
seriously while Jon Bernthal is by far
my favorite casting for Frank Castle of
all the live-action adaptations and he's
a master at making this character
charismatic and tragic I think the sad
reality is that he never really got to
actually be the Punisher except in
daredevil season two in daredevil Byrne
Falls Punisher felt ripped straight out
of the comics and was a dream come true
for fans of the character which are
usually sociopaths or beard fat guys or
edgy teenagers with bad video as say
opinions but upon getting his own show I
noticed a shift in his personality the
show started to rewrite or undo a lot of
the most interesting things about the
Punisher in my opinion and in order to
make him more likable as a leading man
had to cut back on some of the darker
aspects of his personality being a major
fan of the character I still love the
show and I think it's worthy of the name
but today I want to talk about why
Netflix's Punisher doesn't really get
the Punisher right away the first season
starts with an amazing montage of well
just Frank being himself a tactical
genius of violent and unstoppable force
of nature and a man with nothing to lose
then he gets his revenge and just kind
of quits after that we can see Frank
leading a solitary life as a common
worker under a fake name which actually
in the comics was his real name and the
other name as a fake name whatever just
trying to distance himself from his
violent past and find some new kind of
peace for the rest of the series Frank
struggles with a central conflict that's
just kind of wrong for the character he
isn't sure if he wants to keep killing
he's conflicted about taking further
steps towards revenge but finds himself
constantly being compelled to it either
by outside sources or by his own
internal sadness but if there's one
thing I can
with the Punisher it's not having qualms
about morality of killing let me really
ask you what does the Punisher do he
hunts down he kills criminals forever
regardless if they had anything to do
with his family's murder he's in
perpetual war with organized crime he
sleeps in a van or whatever warehouse he
can rent out to keep all of his
equipment he devotes his every waking
moment to the everlasting battle with
the killers and abusers of the world
does he ever feel bad about it does he
ever regret any of it does he ever want
to take a break and live a normal life
not even once
in order to really dig deep in all of
this I think it's time to really brush
up on our knowledge of the history of
comic Frank Castle so he can compare him
to his streaming service counterpart
after eating so many variations of his
origin story I think I found a major
commonality between all these different
tanks Frank Castle was conflicted about
killing at one point in his life but now
he is not and he never will be again
break discovered during his time in the
military that he loves killing people he
feels comfortable when he's in the
middle of a war
it gives him purpose it gives him drive
and motivation and it allows him to be
creative and express himself and it's
even an outlet for his aggression
basically Frank Castle feels like he's
his best self when he's in the middle of
war and it only feels right if the
opponent can fight back which is why he
didn't just start butchering any random
Joe on the street after he got
discharged he enjoys a target that
requires a strategy and forethought and
he gets off a little on the danger the
thing he was conflicted about was who he
could possibly choose for his new war
now that his official one had ended now
he finds himself adjusting to a normal
life with a family to take care of and
responsibilities as a man that he placed
ahead of his urges towards violence he
couldn't let himself just give up being
a normal person no matter how much he
wanted to hurt people his love for his
family kept him grounded enough to shake
off all those urges but he wasn't truly
happy sure he lazily react limited to
life as a bystander and life felt empty
even with his wife Maria and his kid
Lisa and Frank jr. he no longer had a
calling or a direction he certainly
wasn't going to unleash his infinite
fury on the cops or government or
and bystanders he respects good men in
uniforms who were just following orders
something season two of daredevil
showcases quite well during episode
three
but then something tragic and unexpected
happens Frank castles family goes on a
picnic in Central Park and they wander
too close to a couple of mafia guys
assassinating some poor schmuck so Frank
and his family are executed because
these guys can't have any witnesses but
by some miracle or curse Frank survived
his wounds and now things have changed
he found his answer the magic solution
to his inner conflict he no longer had a
family in a personal life holding him
back or keeping him in the realm of
sanity everything that pushed him to
remain human and good was gone and worse
yet he now had a target that he could go
to war with and feel no guilt over he
doesn't respect hitmen drug pushers and
cop killers and he knows they'll always
fight back presenting him with new
challenges so he can adapt and overcome
Frank lost his family that day but he
found himself his true calling and life
was dropped right in his lap and now he
can use all sorts of excuses to justify
it as some kind of moral crusade he
mourns his family and he misses them but
he avenged them after almost a few days
of being the Punisher
they can't be his sole motivation for
doing what he does sure he tries to
promote the moral high-ground aspect and
preach that the law doesn't work but
that's all just bravado really he argues
that he's there to protect the world in
a way that the law can't but we all know
that the idea that no one gets a trial
no one can be rehabilitated and no one
deserves a second chance is well kind of
[ __ ] look you guys like Wolverine
Deadpool or venom they were all killers
and Psychopaths at some point but all
three of them became members the
Avengers at some other point and even
Frank gives them a pass and works with
them instead of just making it his
personal mission to annihilate them
knowing full well they've hurt innocent
people his philosophy is full of
exceptions contradictions and hypocrisy
he even dated Elektra for a couple years
on and off knowing full well she was an
assassin and not every hit she made in
her career was on someone deserving but
he got her presence
like the bronzed heart of a crime boss
they killed together and they went on
cute little dates yeah you're really
keeping the bad people off the streets
Frank the fact is Frank really could
have chosen anyone to start his new war
with because strategically killing armed
opponents is his happy place and it was
an eventualities you go back to it but
hardened criminals just happen to fit
his criteria well enough and he doesn't
have to feel any lingering guilt over it
there is no moral conflict for him and
if you still don't believe me let me
show you Exhibit C or for I don't know
Punisher kills the Marvel Universe like
like almost a whole decade before even
Deadpool did it that's impressive
any knowledgeable Punisher fan knows
that the majority of the Punishers best
stories come from writer Garth Ennis
he's the mad man behind Punisher max
which the Netflix shows in 2008 film
Punisher war zone both take heavy
inspiration from Annie's behind Marvel
Knights Punisher which was the
inspiration for the 2004 film and most
of daredevil season two's Punisher stuff
his stories have been formed and shaped
the character so heavily that I think
it's safe to say he knows what he's
talking about in regards to the
character I'll have to admit some bias
though because Ennis is run on Punisher
Max is my favorite comic run of all time
and I hold everything else with the
character's name on it to that standard
of quality early on in his career with
the character and has wrote the story of
an else world where Frank's family is
killed in the collateral damage of a big
superhero battle involving the x-men and
the Avengers and what does he do he
starts going after superheroes and
villains even though the heroes are
objectively good and honorable people
he still justifies it to himself that
they deserve it and he's doing the right
thing until ultimately he saves the last
bullet for himself after wiping them out
because killing good people was too much
for him Frank Castle doesn't want or
care about revenge and he certainly
isn't a versed of violence or conflicted
about it unless he thinks he's done it
to someone undeserving if he feels like
he's killing people who deserve it
he'll never flinch Frank only finds
himself conflicted if he hurts someone
who isn't a bad person
which even then he doesn't want to admit
because of his pride he'd rather die
than admit he was in the wrong because
of all this
castle is one of most interesting
fictional characters out there to me but
I'll still say if you find his method
and ideology totally reasonable
you're just as out of touch with reality
as he is which brings us to Netflix
Punisher in daredevil season 2 he's
everything he needs to be he's driven
remorseless brutal and excessive he
humiliates his biggest detractor
daredevil by forcing him to break his
own moral code he comes up with
elaborate and conniving plans like
putting a corpse decoy in a truck for
the police to shoot at or placing a
razor blade in his own arm to free
himself after getting caught on purpose
and he even admits that killing felt
good to him he takes every opportunity
he can to hurt bad people like this
creep who tries to sell him videos of
underage girls when he just needed
information this is the most Punisher
moment in the history of ever
this guy had nothing to do with his
revenge plot he didn't have to kill this
guy but boy did he want to so he did and
he could sleep like a baby at night
knowing he only took out his rage on
someone that was a scumbag it's easy to
have Frank act more like himself when
he's the antagonist and eventual
reluctant backup for the hero of the
story because that's exactly what he was
conceived as a villain turned antihero
and after trying to kill spider-man he
eventually decided to help him out
because he felt no honor in killing him
because spider-man's not a dick but Jon
Bernthal gave an insanely compelling
performance he just oozes charisma even
as this morally gray character who does
insanely questionable [ __ ] for flimsy
reasons he steals every scene and
upstages every character when Punisher
is not on screen all other characters
should be asking where's Punisher and
they pretty much do I found myself
constantly getting bored with the hand
and Elektra stuff just get back to the
good part what's Frank doing daredevil
season 2 serves as a perfect
introduction in origin story for him
even without showing the events at the
park in full view we don't need to see
his family get killed at the park or
flashbacks of him being a dad
everything we needed to know is spoken
through his monologue while it breaks
the show Don't Tell rule pretty
egregiously it's such an emotional scene
and so beautifully performed that it
paints a picture for us that visuals
probably wouldn't be able to match up to
so again they got him pretty on point in
daredevil but now we get to him in his
own solo show and he's just Wolverine
okay don't freak out we're gonna shift
gears here for a second I'm gonna just
describe a random Wolverine story and I
want you to follow me here because I'm
leading something we start with
Wolverine known badass and cool guy
living somewhere kind of quiet and
remote doing something rather menial
maybe he's just in an apartment reading
books all day and occasionally going
down to the nearby diner to get
breakfast as part of his daily routine
maybe he's just living in the woods and
trying to take in nature maybe he's
working as a logger with his girlfriend
he's pretty happy with it
hell he could just be living in some old
run-down building and paying his bills
by driving a limo service but then
something random happens that requires
him to unleash his rage and kill again
after swearing it off for however long
he gets a taste of the old ultraviolence
in that segues him into the main
adventure of the story where he has to
go after some bad guy that's wronged him
or someone he cares about throughout the
story he proves to be a proficient
killer which both impresses and
frightens his allies and every time he
kills someone else he feels both an
exhilaration and a shame he can't quite
decide between he's constantly battling
with his inner demons he was used to
become a machine for war his whole life
and now he's afraid that it's all he's
capable of his he pines for something
more he has to ask himself constantly do
I like doing SiC radical execution moves
on dudes
while he's covered in entrails he then
succeeds in defeating the villain
through the use of his inner rage but
also shows a spark of compassion as well
to let us know that the anger and his
heart hasn't completely won then he
rides off into the sunset hoping to
settle down again with some new status
quo before violence enters his life once
again that's exactly the [ __ ] plot of
both season 2 Punisher Frank does a
menial job accidentally has to punish
because he can't leave well enough alone
then it gets roped into a mission to
take down a bad guy then gets sad and
goes home and I get it I understand the
decision to just make him Wolverine
because Wolverine is likable and
compelling to a mainstream audience we
can understand his struggle and we can
empathize with the fact that he is
pulled back into situations where he
doesn't want to be his inner conflict in
hesitancy towards kill stabbing people
gives him humanity
the unfortunate reality though is that
this is the exact opposite the Punisher
Frank Castle is a scary concept really
he's an unhinged and violent man that
only finds solace in taking human lives
but he builds himself up on a perceived
moral high ground so he doesn't have to
pay attention to any of the people
telling him that what he's doing is
wrong he can you shut out the criticism
and say yeah you guys are a bunch of
sissies I'm the real hero while it
continues to be by definition a serial
killer I don't find the Punisher
fascinating or interesting because I
agree with his methods and viewpoint I
find him to be an amazing character
because it's interesting to get in the
mindset philosophies if someone that is
so far gone it's the same kind of
feeling you get from watching a
documentary series about some nutjob
like Ted Kaczynski The Punisher is a man
with no humanity left for him it's only
his obsession with the ongoing war that
he's chosen of his own free will to
partake in he's just going after any and
every of mafia dirtbag he can find for
decades in the comics because it's fun
for him sometimes they'll mix it up a
little and chase a super villain or a
terrorist cell in the Middle East but
all that really matters to him is
keeping the game going not wiping out
all crime it goes without saying that
killing every killer in the world is an
impossible goal and he's content with
that he's the dog that chases his own
tail forever knowing full well that he
won't ever get it because it's not about
catching the tail Jon Bernthal Frank
Castle never finds himself at this point
of becoming utterly Hollow he comes damn
close but he doesn't quite reach that
well-oiled unfeeling unwavering machine
of death maybe given a few more seasons
of the show we could have finally gotten
that but as of season 2 this series ends
with him just on the cusp Bernthal
Punisher never just randomly hunts down
a group of criminals to
for catharsis every person he hunts in
season two of daredevil is directly
related to his family's death and then
in season one of his show gets a little
repetitive by revealing it was all just
some crazy Jason Bourne conspiracy
cover-up to take him out of the picture
which is then punctuated by an entirely
new group of dozens and dozens of people
he needs to get revenge on while
building up to wearing the skull he
essentially has to go through the same
character arc twice in a row and by
season two of his own show he's along
for the ride in this other conspiracy
theory that he just gets randomly sucked
into with his own teen sidekick he never
really gets to be the Punisher we know
from the books and I completely and
totally understand why it's hard to make
a character like that marketable the
emotionless crazed obsessive driven
psychopath is kind of hard to sell as
the hero to mainstream audiences and the
only other example of something like
that started to suck after three seasons
it's easier to buy a tortured conflicted
guy trying to run from his past than
what the Punisher actually is he's just
death incarnate in a pair of combat
boots and a trench coat and given the
current political climate in the world
surrounding gun violence mental illness
the treatment of veterans and the
relationship between police and violence
on the streets
holy hell is it a complicated issue to
tackle someone like The Punisher the
show was already controversial enough
and they had to completely rework some
of those more sketchy elements out of
his character can you imagine the media
controversy that would spark if he
really did just lose it and start
hunting down complete strangers at
random like in the comics like someone
who's never wronged him or come in any
contact with him and he just finds them
and kills them that's not heroic
there's no revenge there it's just evil
so it makes sense to put him in a more
personal story where he's avenging his
family's deaths only or then followed up
with a story where he's trying to
protect a vulnerable and scared young
girl from corrupt officials and crazed
yokels his antagonists need to be
something a little more personal for
this show
to avoid all that drama and they did
manage to take a pretty down-to-earth
look at the element of mental health
issues and veterans despite ignoring
some of the other things I think a show
about a more traditional Punisher could
really get people thinking about and
exploring some very topical themes given
the state of things but it was easier to
make this appeal to mass audiences if
they eased off the parts that were more
morally ambiguous again I'd like to make
it clear that I think the two biggest
factors were both making this character
marketable and appealing to casual
viewers and avoiding controversy the
former being the more prominent one in
my eyes but that part I think is most
easily up for debate
despite is inaccuracies to the source
material I can still find this version
of prank Castle the fun assure to be
really interesting to follow and it's a
damn shame we won't get to see more of
him even if he didn't become more like
the comics as the show went on he's one
of many examples of characters having to
be changed in order for an adaptation to
be financially viable much like Spidey
Deadpool for or ant-man and while it's
unfortunate that sometimes the fact that
Hollywood is a business becomes an
overshadowing factor in the final
product The Punisher show still was a
great take on the character and it's sad
to see it go
whether he's conflicted about being who
he is or not Jon Bernthal will always be
unforgettable as the skull adorned
madman with an H II trigger finger
here's hoping this isn't the last we see
of old Franken Castle big thanks to my
buddy Lord cheddar aka Scott for editing
this video I haven't seen it yet because
I'm just talking into a microphone in a
room by myself right now but I can
already tell that it came out fantastic
so go check out his videos and if you
want to hear me talk about the punisher
a little bit more i also did a review of
the ps2 punisher game written by Garth
Ennis and starring Thomas Jane go look
at that I think I think I did a good job
on it next is Hulk
[Music]
[Music]